Deutsche Bank's biggest shareholder is  now a Hamad bin Jassim bin Jaber Al  Thani the transaction hands the Qatari  Royals investment company a stake of  nearly 6% in Germany's biggest lender  and injects nearly 1.8 billion euros of  fresh capital deutsche bank plans to  raise a further 6.3 billion euros  through our rights offering within  months its leadership duo wants to make  sure it meets tougher new international  standards on how much capital banks hold  been undergoing a revaluation and that's  why we've decided to shift priorities  let's replicas that stuff the bank is  now putting more emphasis on investment  banking in particular it wants to beef  up its presence in the US market